hey everybody how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel
so recently i feel like i've talked a
lot about like these internal feelings
i've had about leaving my tech career
and pursuing content creation full time
but i think there's like a really key
important part of the story that i
haven't told yet
and that is about one particular friend
that i have jarvis johnson for those of
you who don't know
is a content creator that makes comedic
commentary youtube videos
and he's like one of the key parts he's
a really important part to my story i've
been friends with jarvis for a while
and so i invited him onto my show muco's
coroner to talk about this
we used to work together at patreon so
on the show we reminisced about all the
old times
we talked about how we literally started
our youtube channels together
and how we both left the tech industry
to pursue content creation full-time
he's just one of those friends where
it's just like
our lives are so interconnected and we
shared such like a special moment in
time
in our careers in our life and so i was
really happy to have him on the show to
talk about all of this so in today's
video i'm going to share with you
highlights from that conversation and i
think it'll be helpful for some of you
who are maybe thinking about making your
own youtube channel
or thinking about leaving your tech
career for something else so
i hope you find some value in this
because i do genuinely believe that
having someone to go through this kind
of really
big transition in your life is a really
helpful thing
and important part to your story and
before we start thank you to felix gray
for sponsoring today's video and the
glasses that i wear daily
so let's get started now i want to get
into that fateful
vidcon 2017 because that is the
beginning
of like how we started doing what we do
now as youtubers which
let me okay let me just say if we had we
could if we could go back in time talk
to 2017 drivers and when you go in july
and we told that yo like in the future
you're going to do this as a good job
i think we both cry our eyes out because
you are
not going to believe this it's like it
seems so
far-fetched i i think about that a lot
because not only
do i do what i do now full-time you also
do it
and at there was a point in time when we
were both like hey
let's like let's like start youtube
channels you know what i mean like
because when we started youtube i
remember like we both went to vidcon
and then we were both like we had both
just loved youtube for
ever and so we were like like we went to
vidcon we were inspired we're like what
if we like just
made youtube channels i think we came to
that conclusion
separately but together at the same time
okay
so what i remember was that we
because not everybody who was at vidcon
with us
did the same had the same track of like
what they were doing because
we were there for work we had a couple
of places that we needed to be
and otherwise people were just like
chilling doing whatever but we were like
going to the youtube panels we were
going to like so you want to be a
youtuber panel right like
so i feel like we were planting those
seeds for ourselves
and it was like okay you know these
these panelists are making it seem like
it's
something that we could maybe do um and
i just remember being in like
big conference rooms going so you say
there's room for my voice on the
internet interesting
interesting dude i remember i think it
was nick jenkins right one of the
producers it was nick jenkins
yeah shout out yeah i remember producer
precise show crash course
yeah i remember specifically going to
his it was about like what
uh like tools you need or what's the
best kind of gear you need to make
youtube videos and he was like
literally the camera that you have and i
was just like oh
like i can
but it's true you know it's like you
really don't
in and as we've gotten i know you filmed
your first video on an iphone right
i did so but i and i bought a dslr like
immediately after
after which i also remember because we
went to coffee futures
are we youtubers i had that footage
still of
us like looking at my dslr going it's
almost like parents like
looking at like a kid or something going
oh look it's got like two eyeballs and
stuff
you know it's like wow it's got a lens
and it's a camera that's crazy
so we started there and then i'm just
kind of
gonna fast forward a little bit here to
kind of like get into
like the leaving part of um our tech
careers because like
yeah i guess like short long story short
jarvis also started making tech
like videos as well that were like
enormously helpful enormously
like funny and fun to watch right
because i was like because i was like
nobody's watching my little
comedic vlogs about my life i guess i'll
make comedic vlogs about my tech life
and i'll like see if like that sticks or
whatever and i definitely feel like
like in my i have this app i don't know
if you remember the app the little
memory
uh yeah but we had way back when but i
have a
thing in my account like in my memories
that is
from the first time we collabed and i
wrote down because you
your video popped off like uh dan life
popped off like
a quite a bit initially but if i scroll
all the way back
to 2017. here we go september 23rd 2017.
day after video 780 subs
i was 480 subs three hours ago wow
thanks my yuko i want to remember this
time
oh my gosh the paper trail yeah yeah so
it's like we collab
september 22nd 2017 and i got 300
subscribers and i was like
holy this is crazy i mean i
i think that's just what's so special
our stories are so incredibly
intertwined
in doing what we do now so yeah
trevor started making like tech videos
but then as you mentioned earlier you
kind of then pivoted to making comedic
commentary videos so now i kind of want
to just land on this spot of just like
like there was a point i remember when
you were like really considering
leaving you're like you're at the time a
software engineering manager too
and you were considering leaving and
there's actually a couple points i think
where we were like
like we were talking about you were like
i don't know if right now is the time
where i'm gonna do this first and then
go with it but like
i guess walk us through like that
journey of like
like how did you start thinking about
leaving your career and then how did you
actually land on doing that so first i
actually am curious to see if you
remember
something because there's definitely
some gaps that are missing from my
memory because i know what like what
like sort of the
direct answer to your question but i
also remember
there's this like internal struggle
within myself
i was kind of trying to get out of just
having to make tech videos to like put
up the numbers or whatever
but i i was looking for something to
like
click and i i wonder if did i ever talk
to you like on our coffee walks or
anything like that
about being like frustrated that i
couldn't like seem to like get things to
click with non-tech videos
because i i i always like in my cause i
was gonna say yeah i was like i'm pretty
sure
but but also i just remember like it
being a double-edged sword because
when you were gaining an audience like
in the tech world
i was kind of like i want that too but
then when i
started going down that path i was like
i don't know if this is what i
want so i was always trying to thread
this needle
where it was like something that is
creatively fulfilling but also like
satisfies a tech audience and so
it would be like i could make sketches
and stuff and tell the story of like
how i got a job at google while like
failing my interviews or whatever which
is a true story that i think is
interesting and has some like
good lessons to it but also whenever
like i would get comments that were like
oh great information but could you like
remove the jokes and i was like you sir
have come to the wrong place
you know it's like how did i how did i
find myself here
right like because this person is
clearly like misunderstanding what this
whole thing is about so yeah do you
remember any of those like frustrations
that i was venting at the time
the way that i remember it is like
february march timeline
i had actually left patreon in october i
think
like right after i got married so we
didn't actually see each other very
often but we would like
call in stuff and then february march
was when i remember we had a lot of
talks about
you leaving your tech career to become a
full-time content creator
and i remember a lot of it was you there
was a lot of like fear
i guess which makes a lot of sense it's
like you know
it's a big jump to go into something
that's so risky i mean i'm gonna say
it's risky it's a risky job
it's very risky yeah not nearly as much
security as there is
in software engineering and tech and i
think like you and i are both very like
analytical
like let's be really careful and not
make hasty decisions kind of people but
in february march i remember like we
talked a bunch about that
and so like i guess like what do you
think it was that like
allowed you to like actually fully like
finally get there
it was in september of 2018 that i
was starting to think about leaving
because
that prior to that month was when i
changed the title of one of my old
videos and it started like blowing up
and then i also like made more videos uh
in that same vein and those were doing
really well
also and so i put in like my soft notice
around september october because
i was like i want to strike while the
iron's hot
and i also had like 300 000 subscribers
at that point and i was getting
frustrated because it's like patreon
is not like a it's not like a job where
i could just like
phone it in you know what i mean i was i
was
responsible i was responsible for
people's careers which i took
very seriously so i wasn't trying to put
that on the the back burner
and i was unfortunately at the time due
to various like
head count constraints on the line for
doing
ic work as well you know uh anti-pattern
don't have your managers write code but
i like
when i became a manager i was not
writing code but then like a few months
in
push came to shove and i like needed to
chime in on a few projects
so it kind of felt like i was working
two jobs and then i had youtube on top
of that and i was like this is too much
i also feel frustrated that i'm not able
to invest
in youtube right now because this very
rare and special thing is happening you
know what i mean
like momentum means a lot in terms of
like youtube growth and stuff
it wasn't that i believed that i
wouldn't be able to
recreate that momentum if i sort of
focused on work or whatever but it was
like i couldn't
figure out but when right like when was
i going to prioritize myself and like
what i
what i wanted and so i tried to because
i never
left the tech industry because i like
hated the tech industry i never left
because i hated my job i actually like
love my job i love everybody there
um and it was
truly that like there was an opportunity
to me on the table to pursue a dream
that i had since i was a kid and i
had a path ahead of me for like for
doing that
and it just so happened that i was at
this like
that year of 2018 was very much
me burning the candle at both ends i was
i'm sure i talked to you about this but
i was like waking up super early
working showing up and to work at like
like utilizing the fact that if you show
up at 10 or 11 at a tech job like
nobody's really batting an eyelash
but i had been up since like six and i
like had
probably wrote like uh why i didn't go
back to google or whatever published
that on youtube
and like came into the office that was
like wearing on me because i could only
do that for so long
so i think that when push came to shove
it was just like this seems like a right
time
to pursue this and it's great because
like there's videos that kind of like
chronic all these moments
like oh i remember i was working on this
specific life hack video
um and i remember i had a call with jack
conte the ceo of patreon
where i just like it was more like a
personal call where it was like
hey i am
feeling like i'm feeling like between
i'm at this inflection point where
i feel like i have this opportunity with
youtube
but i don't really know if it's the
right thing
to like take the leap right and what he
told me and i want to give him full
credit for this was like
as you know this the boss at patreon
like as a ceo i do not want you to leave
but i will say like as a creator you'll
kick yourself if you don't
take this opportunity and from that
point it was like
i feel like i got just enough of a push
to where that
i was like okay i'm going to start
phasing myself out i'm going to tell
everybody that this is what my plan was
and it started
with a um it started very much like
putting my toes in the water where
i was potentially going to work
part-time or i was potentially going to
do some other sort of configuration
right
at patreon staying yeah while sticking
around
and at a certain point i that was
helpful because it kind of got the foot
in the door
but at a certain point i was like i need
a clean break i need
like i feel so overwhelmed with all
these things right now
i don't think i can like really juggle
at all
so i need to um i need to like break
away
and february was actually my last day
at patreon like february 3rd or 4th or
something like that
was my last day full time but i had a
few
months where i was like i'm planning to
leave so let's like
start let's hire my replacement let's
finish up these projects or whatever
uh and so i spent those months like
wrapping things up so it was a very long
phase out um but that was just because i
cared about
the people around me and i cared about
like not leaving things in like a super
a super twisted or like complicated
situation i wanted it to be as clean a
break as possible
yeah i feel like one of the things that
as i've like talked to more and more
people who've made a jump from
their tech career into maybe content
creation or something else is there is
there's this kind of like stars align
moment where it's like
it's not like the stars aren't ever
gonna align again but it's like
the distance between jumping from this
platform to this platform is as short as
it's ever been
and while it's not it's still not easy
to make the jump it's
like an opportunity to do so and so like
everyone makes a decision on whether to
do that at the time or not
and the other thing that i think like is
really interesting that like i think
your story was the first thing that
really made me
think this way and i've seen it since
too of just like
some people when they think about like
leaving their tech career they're just
like like they
imagine it to be just like i'm done i
quit
hand on my notice today and that's it
and there are some people who do that
but like more often than not
i found that it's a lot about just like
literally having conversations with your
manager
like making sure that you are phasing
yourself out and like
really kind of taking slow incremental
steps to get to a point where
you feel okay about leaving like it's
both kind of like a
journey not just for taking care of the
people who you're working with and the
code but it's also kind of like a slow
emotional journey for yourself too
because yeah like when i joined netflix
i told my manager i was like i don't
know if this is what i want to do but
i'm here to explore it and she was like
yeah explore and so i spent the whole
year being like
um i think this is still what i want to
do and so by the time that i jumped she
was just like yeah this is kind of a
no-brainer like you've told me this
before and it makes sense
so i will just say that like everybody's
situation is different
i decided that i wanted to stick around
and like wrap up all the loose ends
you you'd never owe that to a company
you know what i mean
like like if it's the right thing for
you it's the right thing for you and no
one is going to like hold that against
you
i think for me it was more it was less
about the company itself and more about
the individual relationships with the
people
who i was working with i was like
working on a project with tony over here
and i was like okay tony like let's
finish this thing up by tax day and then
i was like over here like
working with my engineers and i was like
let's get you guys into a good place and
i had my pm
you know and it's like it was it was
really just about
like everyone's capacity and intolerance
for this is different but i
knew that i stayed way longer than i
needed to
you know what i mean like i and that was
my own decision and
if if if it was not my own decision then
i would have made
i would have sort of challenged it right
if the company was like
can you stay even longer or can you you
know it's like if there was any sort of
challenge to my own decision i wanted to
make sure it worked for me
first before i put the company's you
know needs above my own because
there could be various livelihood mental
health or whatever concerns
around like a job and if you're in the
position where
you can afford like to like
up and leave your post like that is
itself a privilege and so like if you
find yourself in a similar position to
me just make sure you're being selfish
and like
prioritizing yourself because a thing
that i say and i don't think you can
really like regardless of who you are
you can't really argue with this is that
the company will never be able to pay
you
back the same way that you like invest
into it you know what i mean
or the odds are like so unlikely so when
you're
investing your time your blood sweat and
tears and stuff
you have to know that that may never be
reciprocated
and you have to like feel good about
making that decision because if you're
just
doing it to sacrifice it to the machine
or whatever
it might just be like an obligation that
constrains you rather than something
that empowers you in like your
decision-making process
it's absolutely just like a value
exchange of figuring out like what is
the company getting out of me and what
am i getting out of the company and like
see and really i think that's where the
evaluation starts is just like even just
like
not just leaving your tech career but
leaving a company in general it's like
making sure that you're getting what you
need to live the life that you want and
like you said it's different for
everybody some people need like the
stability or the paycheck or
the environment in which a company
provides but like i think just making
sure that you are
you're checking in with yourself and
that you're honest about what you really
need and that you're getting that and
you're the only person who can really
make exactly you're the only one with
those answers
a lot of people have way more like
financial
safety nets like everyone's situation is
different and you're valid in
prioritizing like your financial
independence before you
leave the stable company and go and join
a startup where things are far less
like uh guaranteed you know thank you
all so much for watching to the very end
i hope you liked the video
if you want to listen to the full
conversation then you can watch the live
recording by becoming a member of my
youtube channel
by clicking the join button down below
you can also listen to the audio
recording which will be available on the
mooco's corner podcast
big thanks to drivers for being on my
show that was just like a super fun show
to have so
i'm glad i could share that all with you
and thank you felix gray for sponsoring
today's video
five years ago felix gray realized that
we're not meant to look at screens all
day
so they design glasses to make screen
time more comfortable
and daily work more effective their
lenses filter through 15 times more blue
light that can make screen time tough
and disrupt your sleep
personally i have the robling in the
color amber toffee
in the low nose bridge fit which i love
because
asian faces we need these low bridge fit
styles and they have a couple of them so
i really like this one
they're really durable they're
lightweight and i can wear these like
all day blue light lenses come standard
starting at 95
and if you add a prescription then it
starts at 145. with a 30-day money-back
guarantee the only thing you have to
lose is eye strain which i did make a
video about eye strain so i'll link that
in the description box down below to
learn more
felix gray actually really has sales but
right now you can get
15 off the entire felix gray site when
you enter promo code cheers at checkout
this offer is valid through may 2nd all
right everybody that's it for today
thank you so much for watching don't
forget to subscribe and i'll see you
next time
bye